a deficiência de cobre pode levar a
problemas de tecido como a lordose que é
uma curva excessiva na parte inferior
das costas e além disso pode também
estar relacionado a problemas de hérnias
de disco problemas de dores no joelho
devido ao desgaste da cartilagem
articulações fracas músculos fracos e
resistência reduzida ele também é
necessário para prevenir as varizes das
pernas manter as células brancas do
sangue saudáveis e para transportar o
ferro que é necessário na formação de
hemoglobina outros sinais de deficiência
de cobre são suor excessivo cabelos
grisalhos prematuros tontura e
desorientação pessoal alimentos ricos em
cobr São fígado Miúdos de boi Ostras
frutos do mar cogumelo chitaque abacate
e sementes de gelim